all right a few notable posts on the
david pakman show subreddit now here i'm
not selling you anything many times i am
selling you things here i'm not
you can go to davidpakman.com reddit
where nearly 34 000 of our viewers and
listeners have subscribed for free and
you can post about the show
you can talk to other viewers and
listeners about what's in the news
there's some things you're not allowed
to do because it's a little bit over the
line but there's a lot of things you can
do at davidpakman.com reddit
one user posted
on the scene correspondence
has been my favorite
addition
to the david pakman show seriously david
it's incredibly entertaining but also
wildly useful to get real feedback from
these events i don't know if josh or
luke wind up being recurring
correspondents but i loved watching them
maybe one of the larger events you or
pat could get out in the field too
uh there'd be some security concerns
keep this kind of segment going yeah the
point is taken the feedback to having
two people on the ground in conroe texas
for the rally was fantastic and the the
incredible thing is
because you all are everywhere all over
the country
it is very clear that if there's another
trump rally in you know tulsa oklahoma
maybe or wherever or if there is a um
i i don't know an anti-vaccine protest
in wherever
i think that we now have the audience
size where i can say hey
anybody in
berkeley california or wherever
we'll pay you
to go and interview people at these
events we don't have to fly people
around we don't need you know all these
different things and we can basically
just take
the the money because we want to
compensate these people for their time
that that's the appropriate thing to do
as we did with the texas rally
um and we can say well because you're
already there
the money goes for your time rather than
having to to put money into expenses i
think it's absolutely fantastic we're
going to keep trying to do it and the
one thing is we need to know about the
events early enough um it's hard to say
hey can you go tomorrow so in terms of
trump rallies right now we're not seeing
anything else on trump's calendar
um and we will we will see but one of
the most valuable things is
when right-wing media starts some new
story
whether it's about fouchy or biden or
whatever by having these correspondents
on the ground we can immediately see
whether it's gotten to the trumpists and
whether they're aware of it and how
they're interpreting the new talking
point so it's a it's a fantastic thing
and we are going to keep uh doing it
okay another post on the subreddit david
should get in contact with carhartt
about being their spokesman and there's
a absolutely her i described
so
carhartt
is a brand
that has announced they their employees
are required to be vaccinated and it's
sort of a right-wing associated brand
now i very uh
i don't know that i want to say
ignorantly but
i was having trouble describing what
carhartt is and i said carhartt is a
popular clothing brand
for people who are out doing work
chainsaws and whatever i meant that it
is a brand of clothing
that i believe also has it's not only
warm but it has like protective elements
where i think the material is such that
it has some protection if you regularly
work with sharp objects
uh i don't know anyway so someone made a
made a funny image of carhartt for
people out doing work chainsaws and
whatever but in all seriousness um
carhartt is not unique
there are tons of companies that require
their employees to be vaccinated and i
think
the reason that the carhartt vaccine
requirement triggered so many people is
that there is heavy association between
carhartt and sort of
working alpha right wing male ideology
um but carhartt's doing it carhartt has
said you got to be vaccinated and a lot
of right wingers now
burning their carhartt clothing although
what's funny is i think there are
carhartt items that are flame retardant
because of what they're designed for so
it was actually a prob it was difficult
to actually burn it um which just makes
it all the more funny join the
discussion
at davidpakman.com
reddit